I'm curious because you know you said
[__] so let's get into some sex magic I
think that this is an important topic
just because we're talking about so many
things that are kind of out of our
control but what we can control is our
our our manifesting capabilities and I
love the manifesting aspect of Sex Magic
and how to call that in and bring into
fruition the life that you want so
how do we do that
girl let me tell you it works I've done
absolutely everything was Sex Magic um
and and also
for me there is a deep
support system that can be accessed
through a more powerful relationship
with the planet with Mother Earth with
nature I find that because we're using
the body for Sex Magic and the body is
the fundamental Earthly element it is
this Foundation upon which we not only
we grow but our spirit grows our energy
amplifies Sex Magic is literally just
utilizing your sexual energy for magic
whether that's accessing your
Supernatural gifts or healing or
amplifying your personal power or
creating a dream actualizing a vision
how I have learned Sex Magic there's so
many different practices there's Celtic
Sex Magic and there's more you know
Egyptian like I would say that there's a
lot of sound in the Egyptian lineage
when we're talking about like these
Chambers and what the pyramids were
really for finding the path like I like
to call it your intuition that's the
name of my book as well and you're your
intuition your inner wisdom your inner
guided system is always going to guide
you to whatever the thing is that's
right for you so my personal practice
that I have learned from my tantric
lineage is about
using breath sound and movement through
the chakra system so you start at the
root and it's red and it's Primal and
it's the Earth element so it's like the
animal nature of who you are and then
it's into the womb or the sacral chakra
this is watery it's it can be associated
with orange so you like swirl this warm
golden energy in that chalice inside of
you which again men and women you still
have a sacral shocker you have that
that's where our our holy Waters right
our Sweet Waters of our our genitals and
our sexual organs all live for all of us
so you tune into like the flow and the
sensual nature of what this this thing
is that you're amplifying you rise up
into the solar plexus chakra again this
is with breath and sound and movement
what is the fire inside of you sound
like what is the what is the movement of
like that fiery action within you this
is again the solar plexus is our as our
chakra of action so that's a really
important place as you you're doing this
Sex Magic to really follow what your
body wants to do if you want to like
shake or like get super weird then like
you have to do that because that is the
portal of transformation that is the
fire element within us like let me take
action let me do the thing that I'm
guided to do so are you moving then with
the feeling in each chakra you're kind
of allowing your body to move whether
it's through
personal pleasure or whether it's
through dance is that it's however your
body I've done this practice in every
position I've done it I've done it
standing I've done it with two hands
I've done it with one hand in all
different ways
um yeah and I I was actually celibate
for three years before I met my partner
and I was doing this practice a lot so
um so yeah it is generally like with
self-pleasure if you really want to like
use it to its highest benefit you're
working through the chakras yes breath
sound and movement with self-pleasure or
with pleasure with your partner got it
okay cool so then you're rising up your
heart is is breath it's it's green it's
like gratitude it's expansion you're
breathing into your heart and again like
you can be in any position you can be
laying down and it can the dance can
take you over or like you want to just
be adding more breath whatever it is
like it's such a unique individual
practice I mean I do this in in like
Community with my my sisters and we
actually did finally just do some some
co-ed sex magic recently that's been
like integrated into community and like
I've seen people do all kinds kinds of
things doing this practice like you can
do it from any position any props you
want to use I've seen fruit be used in
really beautiful ways like you just make
it your own and then you're in the heart
chakra it's green it's breath again
it's the expansive nature of love like
what does it feel like to have this
thing or to be in this place or whatever
it is that you're amplifying and
manifesting like what's the love that
you feel for it then you go up into the
throat chakra and it's blue and it's
free and like this is a great place to
like especially for people like when I
lead Sex Magic in my Retreats anyone who
like hasn't made a sound yet you can
just feel like then
yeah like all the sounds emerge finally
like at the at the throat and then you
bring it up into your vision and you
really think about it and feel into it
like what is this thing like what are
the thoughts that I have already having
this what are the thoughts that are
completely healed from my mind the old
negative limiting beliefs to like
[__] I don't that isn't helping me
get this and you and you can really
cleanse that with your Sexual Energy
again you're you're lifting this energy
from the base of your spine from your
root through your whole body charging
all of your energy centers so when you
reach your mind
I like to see it as like purple some
people you know say it's Indigo or some
people say that it's already white and
then the crown doesn't have a color
again you get to do whatever you want
but like I love purple it's a very Regal
color to me it also is a combination
when you think about the colors of the
rainbow in the body it's a combination
of the root and the throat so it feels
to me like this blending of like my
grounded foundation and my full
expression and then that becoming the
the
illustration of my own royalty so I love
to like see this purple energy just like
cleansing through my brain and like
washing all of my thoughts and then you
let the pleasure rise up into your crowd
and and for me I love just like
connecting to the Divine connecting to
god goddess Universal Consciousness and
like feeling your pleasure as a gift
from the the goddess or or from the
universe like what an incredible
blessing that we can even access these
climatic States and then from there
with your vision you you know you don't
have to rush right there's no rushing
I'm like in the big groups like I don't
know there's pressure sometimes it's
weird I'm like always the last one to
come everyone's like had this whole like
big giant roaring orgasm and then I'm
like doing it later so you just take
your time no pressure you never force
yourself and then you you in this
connection to the Divine you let this
waterfall of pleasure the waterfall of
experiencing your manifestation just
wash all over you and how I've learned
it from Layla Martin
dear sister
um OG Tantra teacher
she calls it your five senses reality
and that fountain that washes down over
you is what you see what you hear what
you feel what you touch what you taste
what you experience what you smell in
the reality of already having this thing
yeah so I did this for my book deal I
did this for my partner I've done this
for amounts of money I've done this for
programs and all of these things like
I've done this for so many different
things
um that like have all come to fruition
in my life and
um it's really about like truly
understanding what is what's different
if my life here and now looks like this
and my life here and now looks like that
smells like that feels like that what
what are the big things in between and
then at orgasm or at Peak pleasure again
there also isn't like you don't have to
orgasm there's no pressure like never
put any pressure on yourself with sex
magic and also don't do it when you're
like feeling super down because then you
might just like get down on yourself if
you don't orgasm not a good idea you
want to do this like in a high
vibrational State and that Fountain is
your five senses reality it's like the
most empowered version of your
imagination that you can possibly use
and you just let that wash over you and
Cascade down upon you and bask in that
immersive vision and scene as long as
you possibly can and so that's how I've
learned it you can integrate so many
other practices sigils and mirror work
and like with your partner or by
yourself like there's
hundreds of different ways to do sex
magic but that's the one that I was
really utilizing consistently throughout
my time by myself
um that helped me draw my partner into
my life and then um that yeah like
maintaining that practice in my
community has
um been really a huge blessing for my
business because again we're using that
creative and Sexual Energy and like when
you're calling something in from a state
of pleasure I mean the universe wouldn't
make orgasms feel so good if it didn't
like us having them and I think that
like I think that the Big Bang like to
me is like a big Cosmic orgasm like
yourself yeah I mean you're right that's
so good it's it is so good the whole
universe is rocking
um so why in a group though I'm curious
about that
why not I don't know if there's a bigger
reason is it an amplification of
frequency and is it more about
Liberation oh my goddess The Liberation
at least at least for me in my early 20s
like living with roommates and stuff
right like the only time I had ever
heard a woman having sex or like having
pleasure was either like behind a closed
door you're kind of like you're either
at a party or like it's a roommate or
you're not you know you're like not
supposed to hear it but you're just like
sitting in your room trying to just like
live your life or it's your parents or
it's I don't watch porn but you know or
it's porn or whatever and there's kind
of this like I shouldn't see this I
shouldn't hear this I shouldn't know
that this is happening we all have
horrible memories of her hearing our
parents at least once in our life
exactly I walked in online the first
time I ever did that practice with
sisters in a circle it was so profoundly
healing to let it be acceptable to be
heard and to hear someone else like we
started doing it in um during uh this
teacher training and it's part of the
homework and so you you just do it on
your own but it was like a bunch of us
living in L.A hey girlfriend what you
doing tonight
um so I was wondering
exactly no literally we became Aussie
Church do it so every Sunday morning we
would do Sex Magic and brunch you know
when I lead it at my Retreats the
unanimous response is I was so terrified
I was so worried I was so uncomfortable
and then at the end it just felt like
the most natural thing ever it just felt
so right to support another woman's
pleasure to to be there to like amplify
it one of my other friends was like
trying to get a book deal we all did Sex
Magic and she told us her five senses
reality and then we all did Sex Magic to
with that intention it's about
amplification certainly but it's it's
more about just healing the stigmas and
yeah
could you go do did you do Dr Bronner's
car wash at
um at uh Burning Man
so I've heard that similar like
obviously it's not orgasming together
but I've heard it's similar that you
know you basically so for those who
don't know I mean this is like a little
bit more of a you know risque thing to
do at Burning Man you don't have to do
it I didn't do it I almost did it the
last day and then it was a whiteout and
I was like I'm not gonna go like shower
and then be covered in dust so but you
go and you get naked and you you go
through the car wash they hose you off
with soap and then they rinse you off
and then you go on the dance floor and
they're playing music and you kind of
dance and dry off and the stories that
come from that from people that have
helped like sort of like Sherpa and
Shaman people through it to like be
brave enough is that these women are so
liberated afterwards and they feel so
much more confident and I think it's
because you know you see how human
everybody is and you know you're you're
there's no fears you're not thinking you
you go in thinking maybe I'm gonna be
weird or I'm not gonna look right or
sound right or feel right and then you
realize that it you're all the same are
there any other sort of ancient rituals
or practices that you'd like to sort of
call to attention that you think people
should be practicing right now oh
Hallelujah yeah it's so glad you asked
me that because I just um was so blessed
this is not something I would have
normally dropped into this conversation
perfect
but I'm really glad that you asked
because I actually just had the
incredible blessing of participating in
a bison harvesting ceremony if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen